أَنَّ أَنَّ أَنَّ  إِنَّ إِنَّ إِنَّ
وَالشَّمْسُ البُرْتُقَالِي  نَزَعْتُ يَوْمًا سِنَّةْ
كُنْتُ يَوْمًا صَغِيرًا  لاَلاَ لاَ كُنْتُ كَبِيرَا
مَلأْتُ جُيُوبِي حَلْوَى  مُلَوَّنَةً كَثِيرَةْ
آَخُذُ مِنْ ذَاكَ الجَيْبَ  وأُقَرْقِشُ أُصْدِرُ جَلَبَةْ
كُنْتُ فَخُورًا وَفَجْأَةْ  عَضَضَتُ حَلْوَى صُلْبَةْ
أَسْقَطْتُ هُنَالِكَ سِنَّا
أَنَّ أَنَّ أَنَّ  إِنَّ إِنَّ إِنَّ
وَالشَّمْسُ البُرْتُقَالِي  نَزَعْتُ يَوْمًا سِنَّةْ
كُنْتُ قَدِيمًا فَتِيَا  ذُو عَضَلاتٍ قَوِيَّةْ
أَمْشِي وأَهُزُّ الأَرْضَ  لِي أَسْنَاٌن عَاجِيَّةْ
وفِي يَوْمٍ مَطِيرِ  نَزَلْتُ مِنْ سَرِيرِي
حَتَّى أَلْهُو ولَكِنْ  تَعَثَّرْتُ بِسَيْرِي
أَسْقَطْتُ هُنَالِكَ سِنَّا
أَنَّ أَنَّ أَنَّ  إِنَّ إِنَّ إِنَّ
وَالشَّمْسُ البُرْتُقَالِي  نَزَعْتُ يَوْمًا سِنَّةْ